alexandrine que tudiants en journalisme
elle devrait être en angleterre en ce
moment kovy de 19 oblige le pays et
reconfirme et jusqu'à début mars et
depuis le 1er janvier
le royaume uni ne fait plus partie de
l'union européenne
le bric site est entrée en vigueur j'ai
commencé mes études avant décembre 2020
ça veut dire que j'ai juste à
m'appliquer à un truc qui s'appelle lieu
pin salon met ce crime qui me permet de
rester allons bien mes études et de
vivre et et de travailler à londres où
dont l'angleterre a mais les gens qui
commencent vont l'année prochaine en
septembre
ils n'auront pas le droit d'avoir un
prêt étudiant pour les études ils ont
besoin d'un visa qui coûte environ 400
euros et aussi lors des prix
international du coup les écoles et
master pour vite fait passer à 30 milles
rôle de 10 plus tard alexandrine
souhaite travailler au royaume uni une
envie que partage zoé étudiante en droit
et anglais pour elle qui devait partir
en erasmus en septembre ce sera
peut-être plus compliqué moi j'aimerais
beaucoup travailler en diplomatie
faire de la relation internationale et
j'aurais énormément travaillé énormément
aimé travailler en ambassade
après je pense que ce sera toujours
possible enfin j'espère en tout cas mais
je pense que c'est un fou chouia plus
compliqué parce que justement on n'a pas
tous ses accords avec l'union européenne
qui permet à tous les travailleurs de
bouger un petit peu n'importe où en
europe
outre l'aspect professionnel et
étudiants le bric site impact aussi
leurs vies personnelles par exemple si
un proche souhaitent venir les voir en
angleterre
il faudra désormais un visa actuellement
150 mille européens étudiés au royaume
uni